et la multiplication des gestes
barrières qui nous permettent de nous
protéger au lieu de sept co lucas était
hors de contrôle elle reste mais il ya
un problème plus profond et moi
j'aimerais qu'elles qu'elles puissent
témoigner le docteur doit pouvoir
témoigner on à transformer l'hôpital en
entreprise
à partir du moment où on a décidé que on
faisait la rémunération à l'acte alors
ça paraît compliqué comme formule vous
arrivez à l'hosto vous monsieur hanouna
on vous regarde car pour l'instant vous
êtes un peu malade on dit ouah mais il a
il est un peu trop picolé celui-là il
doit avoir le foie en morceaux au revoir
c'est sûr que c'est pas moi c'est
fernand bien avant c'est peut-être pas
vous mais ça pourrait bon bah alors
autre chose la clope plus rien non plus
manon bon peu importe d'accord donc
alors on dira celui là on le prend
qu'est ce qu'il a il a mal à une oreille
on l'aurait pas à toute vitesse tue tout
trois points d'or le reste on ne peut
pas le voir pourquoi parce qu'on est
payés à l'acte
la clinique elle vous regardez lille
celui-là va mal en point jean veut pas
renvoyer le à l'hôpital public c'est
comme ça que ça se passe moi j'ai vu à
marseille unm a raconté à l'hôpital
public y arriver à un malade avec
accrochée après lui un bout de papier où
il était marqué la maladie qui l'avait
parce qu'à la clinique il en avait pas
voulu il avait envoyé à l'hôpital parce
que la salle et prend donc transformer
l'hôpital en entreprise c'est de la
bêtise numéro un aucune personne surtout
sabrina à des sifflets j'aimerais avoir
aujourd'hui monsieur hanouna dans quelle
situation c'est à dire que effectivement
comme dit jean luc on nous a fait une
montagne
d'administratifs donc pour vous donner
l'exemple sylla vous arriver demain avec
une cheville cassée mais ça suffit comme
ça on sait bien que vous en ferez des
moyens porter lâche comme ça suffit
maintenant oui alors oui donc vous allez
assez un code-barres comme un os comme
au supermarché
vous arriver là avec ça une fois que
vous êtes là dedans vous appartenez en
ghm un groupe homogène de malades pour
lequel on ag hs un groupe homogène de
séjour et en calcul que pour un homme de
35 ans avec la cheville cassée si vous
faites pas l'appendicite en même temps
là dms durée moyenne de séjour va être
de cinq jours bon si vous devez passer
ça le service y perd de l'argent si vous
faites moins que ça on gagne de l'argent
donc en fait plus vous fait d'actes plus
on fait opérer mettre des perfs et
cetera hélas le service il est en route
une personne âgée qui est opéré de sa
fracture du cou deux fémurs mais qui est
seul qui est veuf parce que sa femme est
déjà décédé qui peut donc pas rentrer à
la maison encore parce qu'il marche pas
on l'a déjà opéré il ya plus rien à
faire il ya plus de la kiné mais du coup
ils coûtent de l'argent l'hôpital parce
qu'on le pour eux on lui fait plus rien
à ce moment là donc c'est un patient qui
est pas rentable c'est ce que disait
jean luck là où la clinique du coup
celui là quand il vous dit diabétiques
hypertendus et ses dépens dans un
continent ils en veulent pas et toutes
ces charges la elle retombe sur
l'hôpital et vous allez lire mais c'est
terrible ce qu'on fait pour pas que
l'argent parce que quand un service y
perd de l'argent on lui dit on enlève
une aide soignant parce qu'avec ton
activité t'as pas besoin de tant de
personnel donc on se le passe de service
en service pour pas être déficitaire
vous allez lui faire faire une semaine
en gériatrie une semaine en europe non
mais c'est ça il faut que les
entraîneurs on sent ce que vous dites ce
que vous avez la dame qui va les voir
son mari qui sait plus où aller et nous
on s'appelle on dit abattu la déguiser
empaqueter noël parce que pour que le
ssr en face soins de suite et de
rééducation et vous le prennent comme
moi aussi ils sont en sous-effectifs et
que la dame elle vient là et que vous on
vous met la pression parce qu'il faut
virer parce qu'en plus aux urgences y
ait là que et qu'il ya d'autres gens qui
attendent des lits ben vous mentez vous
mettez un dossier vous ajoutez 2 kg vous
mettez pas qu'il est un continent vous
cache là son nom dit pas qui chutent la
nuit et du coup il s'en va et là bas ils
appellent ça les paquets surprise donc à
la fin on est arrivé un truc où c'est
l'infirmière cadre de l'epa qui vient
vérifier avant l'état du malade pour
être sûr qu'on lui ment pas mais mais on
marche sur la tête mais c'est sa
l'hôpital c'est tout parce qu'on sent
que ça c'est du concret là de ce double
a été tout ça ternit c'est fou c'est
qu'on brise donc c'est ça qu'aujourd'hui
qui est plus possible moi j'aime y est
j'ai demandé à jean luc mélenchon et les
équipes si on pouvait mettre déjà des
choses très concrètes dès qu'on arrive à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui il ya des choses
qui sont plus possibles déjà pour que
les gens s'en aillent plus fous qu'on
puisse travailler correctement quand
vous êtes au jour gens ce qu'ils nous
enlevez vous manque un électro font
courir au troisième étage parce que dès
que vous avez deux personnes devant une
des portes aura six qu'il vous faut un
deuxième électro bien chaud il un appui
les cas c'est donc faut aller au
troisième étage leur demander la
bouteille d'oxygène il faut demander au
dessus la ponction lombaire on n'a même
pas de coussin pour que les gens il
s'enroule en couleurs manteau donc si
déjà tout de suite et ils m'ont dit oui
on a dit on fait une liste service par
service des fois c'est des stylos qui
nous manque tout le monde marque de quoi
il a besoin pour travailler correctement
il manque deux brancardiers ok parce que
combien de fois les internes on peut pas
aller soigner les gens parce qu'on
brocarde moi quand j'étais en gynéco ici
à bichât une dame il a descendent de
gériatrie elle doit faire son
échographie de l'endomètre je vois les
patientes les unes après les autres l on
a fini de l'avoir au 3h15 la mamie après
il y avait que deux brancardiers donc le
temps qu'ils fassent tous les transferts
qui doivent faire dont les blocs en
urgence la mamie elle avait au moins 80
ans elle est comme ça sur une chaise
voulons contre un mur au bout d'un
moment vous avez de l'appel moi je
quitte mon tard et du coup je prends la
chaise roulante pour la remontée et
c'est ce que fait tout le monde à
l'hôpital c'est que vous avez un
glissement de tâches énormes parce qu'on
manque de personnel parce qu'on manque
de matériel et que tout est comme ça